ونعت سرايا القدس الجناح العسكري لحركه
الجهاد الاسلامي الشهداء يزن الجعبري وعز
الدين وامجد داخليه الذين سقطوا برصاص
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في قريه جبع
وبلده اليامون في منطقه جنين وقالت سرايا
القدس في بيان ان مقاتليها تمكنوا من
استهداف قوات الاحتلال بالرصاص خلال
اقتحامه اقتحامها قريه جبع جنوب جنين صباح
اليوم
في ردود الفعل قالت حركته حماس ان السياسه
العدوانيه التي تنتهجها حكومه الاحتلال لن
تمنحها ان المزعوما على الاراضي
الفلسطينيه وفق تعبيرها ودعت الحركه
مع جيش الاحتلال والتصدي لعدوانه في كل
الساحات قال المتحدث باسم حركه فتح منذر
الحايك ان جريمه جيش الاحتلال في جنين
رسالته تحدي للعالم والقانون الدولي دون
اي راده موضحا ان المجتمع الدولي لا يزال
عن توفير الحمايه للشعب الفلسطيني من
جانبها قالت الجبهه الشعبيه لتحرير فلسطين
في بيان ان العنوان الاسرائيليه المفتوح
على الشعب الفلسطيني ما كان ليصل الى هذا
الحد الخطير لولا حاله العجز العربيه
والدوليه والدعم والحمايه التي توفرها
الاداره الامريكيه للاحتلال وفقه تعبير
في هذه الاثناء حملها رئيس الوزراء
الفلسطيني محمد اشتيه ما وصفها بحكومه
الاحتلال الاسرائيليه المتطرفه والعنصريه
حملها المسؤوليه الكامله عن هذه الجرائم
وطلب اشتيا العالم بموقفا واضح وتوفير
الحمايه الدوليه للشعب الفلسطيني